you make a reveal in the book that you
and Cassie broke up briefly mm-hmm I
think you said it was because you
weren't communicating as well as you
could have been what were you not
communicating well about and then how
did you learn to move forward from that
I put a lot of pressure on our
relationship and I sort of was always
defending it or I was overcompensating
and trying too hard and that was the
case I was almost pushing her away by
trying to bring her closer saying like
no we'll be fine we'll be engaged by
this date will do this will do this will
do this and it was sort of overwhelming
her all over again of being like we need
to talk about this you can't just like
go out in the media and say this or you
can't just tweet about this or Instagram
like this without communicating and
talking with me and we both just a lot
of let a lot of things little things
build up because you know we got busy I
mean she was doing a lot of things on
her own I was doing things in my own
forgot that what made us so strong
together was that communication and
working through problems together and
being there for one another and being a
team so where do you see you guys's
relationship now in terms of it sounds
like you are so solid together but you
know do you kind of take it day-by-day
could you potentially briefly break up
again in the future and reunite again in
the future like what kind of
conversations do you have about that
yeah I mean we're a normal couple I mean
this there is no certainty right now I
mean we're not engaged we're not married
I love her to bits and pieces and I
think that for us we just need to keep
communicating and having those open
conversations with one another I mean I
don't to answer your question I mean
we're just taking it day-by-day right
wait you're married you know at this
point where we are in the middle of a
global pandemic Colton we don't know
I've known you for a while now I've been
interviewing you for a couple of years
and when I heard about some of the stuff
in this book I thought wow Colton is
really digging in and he's really
opening his heart to everybody um the
question though that everybody is gonna
ask you is do you reveal in the book
whether you've had that first time yet
I'm sure you're already getting this
question you know I have a quote in the
book that says nobody talks about your
sex life unless you don't have one
and that's all people want to talk about
and I understand by me you know talking
about it naming the book that it's gonna
bring up those questions again Cass and
I for our relationship have decided that
we don't want to share that it's a it's
sort of funny because I feel like her
baby announcement will be my virginity
announcement all at the same time so you
sort of get a two-for-one whammy when we
decide that we're ready to have kids but
you know what I it's just at this point
we're just we sort of just like laugh
and smile and move on so you and Cass
talk about having kids we do it we still
talk about our future and we decided
that we're not moving in together until
we're married
so we we have that to look forward to as
a next step in our relationship but as
far as like timeline everything we still
talk about you know her finishing school
and what's funny thing about that this
quarantine is a lot of relationships
have not too dissimilar Lea from The
Bachelor been thrust together a
spotlighting your communication because
you're only talking to each other I
wondered if you guys have had
discussions on has this moved you closer
to a proposal or maybe said to you okay
let's let's keep on the pace where is it
well to be honest with you for me I mean
I slept 16 17 hours that look a few of
those days because I've been dealing
with the sickness I haven't been with
the family so I it sort of been how
strict next to next to me I mean yes
they nursed me back to life but I
haven't had them if you want to call it
microwave the relationship like
everybody else is because I've been
fighting this thing off so I don't know
maybe who knows what our next two or
three weeks have in store for us when I
can finally rejoin them whoa did you
just tell me you're gonna propose
oh no I turning this time would it be a
corona proposal oh so you are on the
upstairs floor of Cassie's family's
house I know she's been kind of running
you food and medicine but you've
essentially been isolated even in a
house with other people what's that been
like for you how have you passed the
time because you're a guy who stays busy
I am
that's been the hardest thing and I've
been trying to practice self love and
self care and really value and take that
take this time for myself but mentally I
mean you know this I've been very open
with my mental health it's been a
struggle from a lot of the messages have
been positive but there's still people
out there that are confused or mad that
I got a test or upset that I'm sharing
or not sharing the medication there's no
there is no game plan for this there's
no right or wrong ways to do it I'm I
hope that I'm by me being transparent
and sharing with people that helps
people but it's been a challenge
mentally I'm not gonna lie like it's
been very isolating at times alone at
times but we're all in this together and
I have to keep that perspective that you
know there's nothing more important
going on in the world right now in
taking care of not only yourself other
people as well it has the gift kind of
given you a new appreciation for Cassie
and her family as they have nursed you
back to health
100% um it's been so incredible
literally having Amy like be my little
nurse and Cassie be there for me masks
and gloves on supporting me and eating
breakfast with me six seven feet apart
and Matt has made some killer food for
me while I was recovering so it's been
good for all of us I think I told you
and Chris it's been like a hometown mix
with a happy couple all at the same time
and it's been fun as fun as you can make
it in quarantine and in isolation but
they've kept me in really good spirits
you're in great shape you are a former
NFL player that's a pretty elite group
of strong athletic people what is it
felt like for you and especially at its
worst for me it was it was like I had
access to only 20% of my lungs and I
think the coughing the reason why the
coughing is so scary and so hard to deal
with is because when you cough you can't
get that air back as quickly as you
normally can I think for me the scariest
part is actually feeling you feeling
yourself breathe were there moments
you were scare there definitely was I
think that Saturday and that Sunday I
tried to put a brave face on just
because obviously Cass and her family
and especially at that time I didn't
know if they were going to be getting it
um I was scared for them I was scared
for myself I didn't know I think that
the scariest part is is the unknown
nobody knows what this thing does how
long it's gonna last if it has any
permanent damage I mean I don't know if
I can get it again or if I could relapse
so I it's just a scary time right now
and I think that's like the the most
frightening thing for everybody what
have you been doing have you been
watching TV trying to stay off social
media on it because even if you're able
to talk to somebody you know from
downstairs or something it's still a lot
of alone time yeah I've actually used my
time to call people that I might not
have had enough time for and my busy
schedule prior to all of this I've been
talking with my grandma my grandparents
back in Illinois quite a bit all my
hands sitting on my cousins and then
I've watched a little bit of Netflix
here and there and I played some video
games I've taken it all the way back to
playing video games and hanging out and
with the little headset on so I'm trying
to stay busy and then now I'm promoting
my book which is weird timing for all of
this but you know what if anybody could
take anything from it I'm I'm grateful
to have them read it
[Music]